someone just said i'm 21 i come from a
poor family i have an insane work ethic
tell me how to get rich neval
okay let's let's do it um so
you know that's what i did my famous
tweet storm about it's pinned on my
profile you should go read it of course
every one of those tweets can be
extrapolated into you know an hour's
worth of conversation
but that's a good starting point you
kind of want to absorb all the different
pieces and whatever you don't understand
i can i can always extrapolate on much
more but i would say you know the first
thing that this person asked about how
do i get rich they said i'm 21 of an
insane work ethic
it's not really work ethic that matters
you know unfortunately there are people
who bust their butts 80 hours a week 120
hours a week whatever the same numbers
are and they don't get rich so it's not
really about hard work right you can
work in a restaurant uh you know 80
hours a week and you're not gonna get
rich so it's about
knowing what to do and knowing who to do
it with and when to do it so it is much
more about understanding than is purely
about hard work yes hard work matters
and you can't skimp on it but it has to
be directed in the right way and if you
don't know yet uh what you you should be
working on then that is the most
important thing to figure out and you
probably shouldn't be grinding at a lot
of hard work until you figure out what
you should be working on
i i would say that the most important
skill
to
getting rich is becoming a perpetual
learner okay you have to know how to
learn anything you want to learn
there should be no book in the library
that scares you whether it's a math book
or a physics book or electrical
engineering book or a sociology book or
an economics book you should be able to
take any book down off the shelf and
read it and guess what a number of them
are going to be too difficult for you
that's okay read them anyway then go
back and reread them and reread them
when you have when you're reading a book
and you're not understanding a lot of
what it's saying and there's a lot of
confusion in your mind about it that
that confusion is similar to the pain
the burn that you get in a gym when
you're working out you're but this time
you're building mental muscles instead
of building physical muscles so just
learn how to learn and then read the
hard books and the problem with just
giving advice saying just read is that
there's so much junk out there right
there's as many different kinds of
authors as there are people so there are
lots and lots of people who are going to
write lots of junk so this is this is an
unfortunate thing that i find i do have
people in in my life that i consider to
be very well read who aren't very smart
and the reason is because even though
they're very well read they sort of read
the wrong things in the wrong order it's
not even if they read the wrong things
but they read them in the wrong order
because if you
if you start out reading a set of things
that are false or let's just say they're
not even false they're just weakly true
at best then they form the axioms or the
foundation for your worldview and then
when new things come in you judge
whether they're accurate or not based on
that foundation that you've already
built so that foundation is critical so
when it comes to reading i would make
sure that your foundation is very very
high quality and the best way to have a
high quality foundation is unfortunately
you may not love this answer but it's to
stick to science and to stick to the
basics it's better to be really great at
arithmetic in geometry uh than to be
like a
deep into advanced mathematics uh you
know your foundations are very important
it's good to like microeconomics i would
read microeconomics all day long micro
101 i would throw macro economics away
because it's trash people can't agree on
so generally there's only a few things
you can read where people don't really
disagree like very few people will
disagree that two plus two is four right
so that's serious knowledge that's
knowledge everybody should have so
mathematics is a place where you can
rest your head it's a solid foundation
similarly the hard sciences are solid
foundation microeconomics is a solid
foundation the moment you start
wandering out of these solid foundations
you're in trouble because now you don't
know what's true and what's false so i
would focus as much as i could on the
solid foundations another way to do this
is to read the originals read the
classics if you want to learn evolution
read charles darwin don't even read
richard dawkins even though i think he's
great read him later first read charles
darwin you want to you want to learn
macroeconomics first read adam smith
read von mises read hayek you know start
with the original start with the
philosophers of uh of the economy um
even if even if you're into communist or
socialist ideals which i'm personally
not but even if you are start by reading
karl marx uh you know don't read the
current interpretation of whatever
someone is feeding you about how things
should be done and run so if you start
with the originals with the foundations
then you will have enough of a worldview
and understanding that you won't fear
any book and then you can just learn and
if you're a perpetual learning machine
you will never be out of options on how
to make money because you can always see
what's coming up in society what the
value is where the demand is
and you can learn and come up to speed
there's an old model of making money
which is that
the old model making money is like you
go to school you study for four years
you get your degree and then you work in
that profession for 30 years but things
change too fast now so now you have to
come up to speed a new profession within
nine months and it's obsolete four years
later but within those three years that
you're productive in that profession you
can get very wealthy so it's much more
important that you be able to become an
expert in a brand new field within nine
to 12 months than it is that you studied
the right thing a long time ago
all you really care about having studied
before are the foundations so that
you're not scared of any book so if you
go into a library and there's a book
that you cannot read and you cannot
understand then you have to dig down and
say what is the foundation required for
me to learn this and i better go brush
up on those foundations foundations are
super important
you know i will bet you that uh i'm a
little older now so my brain doesn't
work as fast as it used to but in my
prime uh you know you could have come to
me and uh you know we could have for
example done math problems against each
other and i would have lost to you on
every calculus problem but it was a rare
human being who could beat me arithmetic
and
basic arithmetic and numeracy is way
more important than being able to do
calculus in life
similarly being able to convey yourself
simply using ordinary english words is
far more important than being able to
write poetry or having a very extensive
vocabulary
or knowing uh you know seven different
foreign languages
knowing how to just be persuasive when
speaking that sales skill is far more
important than being an expert digital
marketer and click optimizer on the
internet so foundations are key it's
just so much better to be in 9 out of 10
or 10 out of 10 on foundations
than to try and get super deep into
things now you do need to be deep in
something
because otherwise you'll be a mile wide
and an inch deep and you won't get what
you want out of life
but
you can only achieve mastery in one or
two things it's usually the things that
you're obsessed about at that time and
it's the and you have to sink a lot of
time into it almost by definition
so you can't have mastery in everything
but if you if you have the foundations
then you can pick what you want to be
have mastery as opposed to just wish
that
or just have gotten lucky that you
stumbled into it at the right time in
your life early on
another idea that i got
and this may remind you of confucius too
is that wisdom acquisition was a moral
duty it's not something you do
just
to advance in life
wisdom acquisition is a moral duty
and and there's a corollary to that
proposition which is very important
it means
that you're hooked for lifetime learning
and without lifetime
learning
you people are not going to do very well
you are not going to get very far in
life based on what you already know
you're going to advance in life
by what you're going to learn
after you leave here if you take
berkshire
hathaway
which is certainly one of the best
regarded corporations in the world and
may have the best
invest long-term investment record in
the entire history of civilization
the skill
that got berkshire through one decade
would not have sufficed to get it
through the next decade with the
achievements made
without warren buffett being a learning
machine continuous learning machine
the record would have been absolutely
impossible the same is true at lower
walks of life
i constantly see
people rise in life who were not the
smartest sometimes not even the most
diligent
but
they are learning machines
they go to bed
every night a little wiser than they
were when they got up
and boy does that habit help
particularly when you have a long
run ahead of you
alfred north whitehead
said at one time that the rapid advance
of civilization
came only when man invented the method
of invention and of course he was
referring to the
huge growth in gb
gdp per capita and
all the other good things that we now
take for granted which happened just
started a few
hundred years ago
and
when before that all was
stasis and
so if
if
civilization can progress only when it
invents the method of invention
you can progress
only when you learn the method of
learning
i was very lucky
i came to law school
having learned the method of learning
and
nothing has served me
better in my long life
than
continuous
learning
and if you take warren buffett if you
watched him with a time clock
i would say
half
of all the time that he spends is just
sitting on his ass and reading
and a big chunk of the rest of the time
is spent talking one-on-one either on
the telephone or personally
with highly gifted people
whom he trusts and who trust him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you